meanwhile it is one of the country's
busiest sectors for border agents
handling migrant activity but the 245
mile del rio stretch reportedly has a
fraction of the manpower needed to
patrol it they only have 12 agents only
12 is the only federal law enforcement
officers and it's taking a significant
toll one agent claiming morale is low
everyone shows up to work sort of
downtrodden almost dead inside they're
not allowed to do the job and they know
that people are getting away every
single day every single hour
former ice field office director for
buffalo new york thomas feely says
biden's border policies forced him to
step aside
from his role he quit he's joining us on
this monday morning tom good morning to
you
good morning guys thanks for having me
it's great to have you so this 245 mile
stretch they've only got 12 border
patrol agents where's everybody else
so we've got to keep in mind this is
really by design by the biden
administration if you're going to pull
everybody off the line to do processing
for the influx of illegal aliens that
we've had
you know shockingly since january i'm
not sure what occurred in january to
make everybody want to run to the united
states but when you pull everybody off
the line
and put 12 guys to cover 245 miles
you're sending a clear signal to the
boots on the ground that you don't care
you don't have our back and immigration
enforcement's not a priority for you
right and the agents primarily
everybody else is indoors processing the
people who you know
uh went up to a pickup truck and uh just
surrendered themselves hey can you
please process me
what is morale like down in that sector
because if you've only got you know one
in 10 for the number of people you
probably need out on the line how do
they feel about that
you know morale is really low even in
ero enforcement removal operations
because they're being detailed down
there to help out cvp and border patrol
it's low you mean these are a lot of
type a personalities you know they
believe in god and country and want to
do the right thing and enforce the law
and when you take a large group of men
and women like that and tell them hey
you know we know this is what the
constitution says we know what this is
the laws that were passed by congress
say and signed by president clinton in
1996 but you know we just want you to
look the other way and not do anything
and they're gonna have a hard time with
us well you know tom
while we look in and we see oh there's
only 12 agents for 245 miles you know
who loves that the drug cartels because
that means
the chances of them getting their
payload into the united states is much
better
yeah i'm sure steve's you know certainly
here in the near future we'll probably
want to know again you know where all
this fentanyl came from and yeah i was
talking to some local health
professionals here in western new york
yesterday and even their morale is low
you know they're dealing with covet and
not being able to get the right
information out but again it's the biden
administration putting up these
roadblocks stopping all these
professionals from doing what they you
know signed up to do
so the administration wants fewer guys
and gals on the line
oh absolutely this is all by design this
isn't a mistake
uh you know they turned off everything
that president trump tried to do in the
previous administration was securing the
border they know exactly what they're
doing
trust me this is all by design they
don't want the border patrol agents on
the border they want them inside
processing basically wasting time on
these illegal aliens instead of just
turning them around and sending them
home well thanks for the update from our
southern border tom feeling former
director of new york ice removals sir
thank you very much for joining us on
this monday have a great morning